i'm gonna ask you some things as many  questions as i can  [Music]  what time did you go to bed last night  uh  uh 12 15. okay okay okay that's late i  know it's too late okay waffles or  pancakes waffles and why  uh because they can collect the syrup  better i agree what's your your go-to  coffee order the coffee otter is an ice  cold brew okay as opposed to an iced hot  proof  a cold brew over ice i do the same thing  okay uh what's your favorite dessert uh  ice cream not apple pie  you know what i understood okay the new  show cash at your door coming out how  much cash do you have on you right now  uh uh carry the one  i like 100 180 80 80 yeah that'll do we  can get a nice lunch together great  let's go all right that's a wrap he's  gonna take me out  [Music]  you